Hey...
Hey.
So... you remember that film that we shot last month, right?
The one I spent my life saving on? Yeah. I remember that.
So...
Turns out that we have a little bit of a problem.
We kind of shot it the wrong way...
What do you mean?
Uhm... well... uhmmmm....
Here, just look for yourself.
It's all like this?
Yep. Yes it is...
Thanks for watching Microhorror: Shake!
Tell us about your most horrifying fails in the comments.
If you liked this video, remember to like this video and subscribe for new horrors every month.
And click right here to see the last Microhorror, we'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we survive...
Cut! How did that look Camari?
That was goo--